manifestation aujourd'hui à paris contre
la campagne militaire turque au
kurdistan irakien depuis plusieurs mois
la turquie mène une offensive dans le
nord de l'irak contre le pkk une
organisation kurde jugée terroriste
entre autres par ankara mobilisation
suivie par notre reporter david qui est
différent rejoint tout de suite bonjour
david alors la mobilisation est
manifestement au rendez vous
[Musique]
oui grande mobilisation c'était frais
12h01 plusieurs centaines de personnes
se sont réunies place de la république
afin de dénoncer un cette campagne
militaire de la turquie a dans le sud de
kurdistan région qui se trouve au nord
de l'irak l'objectif évidemment et
d'interpeller la communauté
internationale sur ses actions mais
aussi de sensibiliser le gouvernement
français sur l'absence de réaction que
ce soit sur le plan international mais
aussi régional à plusieurs centaines de
personnes vous le disais et comme vous
le voyez une scène a été érigé derrière
moi aidez à prise de parole en public se
succèdent des concerts aussi
personnalités kurdes mais aussi
arménienne se déroule pour cette
mobilisation la volonté des manifestants
est également de montrer leur influence
néfaste d'ardoyne dans cette zone à des
crimes acquis qui suivent la logique
impérialiste du président selon leurs
mots écoutez une région totale du
kurdistan irakien qui est une partie
essentielle de l'irak du territoire
irakien soit annexé par la turquie
m ais je pense à un coup dur avant tout
pour les intérêts de la france mais pas
seulement
pas seulement il ya d'autres pays
également qui dans ce sens là ont leurs
intérêts nous l'avons bien vu en action
en syrie aussi la turquie avait dans ce
sens-là mis en avant l'argument de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
nous avons bien vu aujourd'hui que les
structures terroristes donc en syrie
dans le nord de la syrie ont été
implantés par le biais de la turquie on
a très bien vu aujourd'hui que la
turquie à quel point allait collaborer
avec coopérer avait à ses côtés mener
des alliances en tout cas avec ces
organisations jihadistes dans ce sens là
on sait à quel point la turquie n'est
qu'elle parle de lutte contre le
terrorisme
on voit que c'est l'argument en fait
essentiel pour elles d'un excès une
partie de cette région est d'étendre ses
frontières dans le moyen-orient au bras
afin de revenir sur les anciennes
frontières en tout cas du de l' empire
ottoman les personnalités politiques
sont également venus apporter leur
soutien à cette mobilisation c'est le
cas à de jean christophe sellin
coprésident du parti de gauche pour lui
emmanuel macron a sa part de
responsabilité dans cette île à vis de
cette situation dans cette région
aujourd'hui le kurdistan irakien et le
kurdistan syrien donc leur java y
compris l'expérience démocratique durera
sont aujourd'hui sous les bombes
d'erdogan est que non seulement le
gouvernement français ne fait rien mais
l'automne l'alliance impérialistes dans
laquelle nous nous voulons couvrir ses
agissement puisque la turquie est aussi
membre de l'otan'' d'un véritable
scandale
la politique d' emmanuel macron niveau
international est la même qu'au niveau
français il ya des grands discours mais
la réalité c'est la réalité de de la
realpolitik des alliances et des
intérêts économiques
et malheureusement les droits de l'homme
passent derrière gardois un accusé
également d'être responsables du conflit
arménien en septembre octobre dernier un
profit qui avait plusieurs milliers à
demande de nombreuses âmes arménien
elles sont également présents dans ce
cortège est la mobilisation se poursuit
dans une ambiance assez agressive et une
faible présence à des forces de l'anp
merci à david pour toutes ces précisions